well it looks like we know what Marvel
Studios is going to do for the final
villain of the Multiverse Saga there is
a lot that has happened recently with
Jonathan major being in court being
found guilty Marvel Studios has
officially decided to move on without
Jonathan majors and it looks like both
reports that we have received about the
future of Kang the Conqueror are indeed
true last week we talked about how two
things are happening with Marvel Studios
one is that Avengers King Dynasty is not
avengers King Dynasty anymore and that
does seem to be the case right now over
at Marvel Studios it looks like they are
just referring to it as Avengers 5 right
now however at the same time that
doesn't mean Kang is completely done
according to reports they are simply
sweeping him under the rug for the time
being and he is indeed going to be
returning in Avengers Secret Wars
however it does seem like another
villain is going to play a pretty
prominent role in Avengers Secret Wars
as well and it does seem like Marvel
Studios is going to kind of take a page
from Marvel Comics for Secret Wars so a
lot to break down today it also looks
like we might have a rough release date
4 Avengers 5 and Spider-Man 4 which
we'll talk about of course in this video
so if you're new be sure to subscribe so
you don't miss out on any of the latest
videos and if you subscribe and leave a
comment you're entered in our giveaway
for a chance to win a PS5 an Xbox series
X some Marvel Legends items and some DC
items winner picks one item we pick one
winner at the end of each month and
we're almost at the end of the month so
be sure to subscribe so right away let's
just hit you with the Avengers 5 and
Spider-Man 4 News it looks like
according to Insider Daniel rpk Avengers
5 is not going to be filming until late
2024 this year this is good news because
right now Avengers the King Dynasty is
slated for May 1st of
20126 so the fact that they are starting
filming and production a year and a half
before the movie's release date is
really really good news that gives them
a lot of time to really get things down
like the visual effects plus not to
mention it looks like the story kind of
has to be either scrapped or drastically
changed since King the Conqueror is no
longer going to be the villain of the
movie titled the King Dynasty so
obviously a lot of changes are going to
be happening to Avengers 5 so it's
really good that they have a lot of time
before the actual release date of the
movie this means that the release date
probably won't change and they'll stick
to May 1st 2026 now according to Daniel
rpk Spider-Man 4 is not going to begin
filming until 2025 which some people
have found conf confusing but keep in
mind Spider-Man 4 has always been
reported to be released between Kang
Dynasty and secret WS it's not supposed
to come before Avengers 5 this way they
can work in a Multiverse story a little
bit better since they'll be further
along into the story in the MCU so the
Spider-Man 4 release date is most likely
looking at the end of 2026 because it
has to come after Avengers 5 but this is
actually pretty good news because a lot
of people were expecting some pretty big
delays following Jonathan major being
found guilty and being released from
Marvel but right now it looks like
things are still on schedule which is
great news now diving into King a little
bit more we've always known that the
final villain of Secret Wars was going
to be some type of beyonder variant
insiders have been pretty vague about
what exactly to expect however it looks
like we might finally know how exactly
the beyonder and Kang are going to come
into play in Avengers Secret Wars now
before we thought it might have been a
Kang variant who is the beyonder but
right now it's looking like the beyonder
could simply be himself and we could be
looking at a very comic accurate
beyonder secret War Story here now it
looks like Marvel Studios has a very
specific purpose for the beyonder and
for Kang in secret Wars and it looks
like they are kind of going to be using
this as an excuse to recast Kang that's
at least what The Insider my time to
shine hello stated on December 25th
yesterday she tweeted another one as in
another scoop the beyonder is still the
main villain for Secret Wars that will
be their excuse to recast Kang then to
top it all off Alex Perez another
Insider from the cosmic circus.com
retweeted this tweet simply stating yep
meaning he's heard the same thing so
right off the bat this does tell us that
Kang is indeed going to be staying in
the MCU they are indeed going to push
him to the side for a little bit but
he'll return in a pretty big way in
Avengers Secret Wars and of course he'll
be recast now quick side note a lot of
people are asking well what if Jonathan
Majors appeals and what if he wins will
Marvel Studios and Disney then take him
back and that really is an excellent
question especially since Marvel Studios
and Disney have taken people back before
the perfect example is James gun they
fired him but then he came back to
direct Guardians volume 3 so just based
off of that case with James gun could it
be a possibility yes is it likely I
don't believe so but anything is
possible but for right now according to
all of these insiders it looks like they
are indeed trying to recast and if they
recast before Jonathan major appeals and
before he could possibly win then I
think they're going to stick with who
they chose to replace Jonathan Majors
because that option in their eyes could
be less problematic although I'm sure
fans are going to be up in arms if
Jonathan major wins his appeal and isn't
hired back by Marvel Studios now Alex
Perez from the cosmic circus hinted at
what the story for the beyonder and Kang
is going to be in secret Wars and
honestly it sounds pretty cool and if if
you're a Naruto fan you're going to like
this a Twitter account online posted
this I have a feeling that they're going
to pull a kaguya with the beyonder and
Alex Perez basically confirmed that this
is indeed what they're going to do by
replying with this and if you think
about it it makes a lot of sense and is
basically comic accurate to Secret Wars
now I'll explain what this is for those
who don't know in Naruto they basically
made a villain that was way too powerful
for anybody to defeat so a bigger
villain was introduced to kill him him
kaguya kaguya was much more powerful but
she actually had greater weaknesses that
the heroes could exploit so essentially
she was more vulnerable she was much
more powerful but actually was
defeatable and it looks like that could
be what they're going to be doing with
Kang and the beyonder so Kang could grow
to be way too powerful for anybody to
defeat until the beyonder steps in and
defeats Kang himself and then that's
when the heroes step in to defeat the
Beyond because in the comics Doom takes
the powers of the beyonder and he
becomes God Emperor Doom but I think
there could be a little bit of a Twist
here I think the beyonder could come in
and defeat the Council of Kings but then
I think a king variant could take the
powers of the beyonder and that's how we
get this King beyonder variant that
everybody has been reporting and talking
about for a long time now that way they
make it to where King is still the
villain the villain that has been set up
since basically the beginning of the
Multiverse Saga with Loki season 1 when
they introduced a variant of Kang he who
remains then of course Loki 2 Ant-Man
and the WASP Quantum Mania it would be
nice to see King still be the final big
bat at the end of this all despite
everything that's happened so perhaps
the Council of Kings becomes too
powerful for anybody to defeat which
makes sense they are outside of space
and time they can control space and time
their technology is really just beyond
anything our Avengers have and there's
three of them working together who are
super super powerful and we basically
have already known that in Avengers the
King Dynasty or Avengers 5 originally at
least the heroes were going to lose and
the Multiverse was going to start to
truly fall apart that's how we got our
big multiversal team the Multiverse
falls apart the TVA grabs a bunch of
Heroes they bring them all together from
a bunch of different universes then they
go and they fight King the Conqueror or
the Council of Kings on all the variants
so comic book fans or just anybody who
has read Avengers Secret Wars can see
how this is kind of becoming comic
accurate if if a bunch of Heroes from a
bunch of different universes get
gathered on one planet that's battle
world then if the beyonder shows up and
reveals that he is the one who has
actually been behind everything that is
extremely comic accurate as well and
then instead of Doom taking the powers
of the beyonder they just simply have a
Kang variant take the powers of the
beyonder and then he becomes the true
big bad villain if this happens I think
a lot of people are going to be pretty
happy with how comic accurate the movie
could be and story-wise it makes a lot
of sense
but let us know what you think about
this in the comments down below do you
like this idea do you not like this idea
and who do you think they should get to
recast as king the Conqueror let us know
all your thoughts in the comments down
below don't forget to like the video and
subscribe to stay up to date on the MCU
and ENT our giveaway you can find us on
Instagram and Twitter as well and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof